In astronomy, the attitude is the vertical angle, and the azimuth is the angle
around the horizon. You're job is to add another slider to also very the
altitude angle of the light. To get it right you'll have to take into account
that the x and z components need to be scaled down as the y component
increases. So that the direction is normalized. In other words, the light
direction should be x squared plus y squared plus z squared equals 1. Another
handy formula you'll find is that, the cosine squared plus sine squared equals
1. When you're done, the light should now operate with altitude and azimuth
angles. Another way to think about is that altitude is similar to latitude on
earth, azimuth is similar to the longitude.